ten years ago when Bryce Harper was on
the cover of Sports Illustrated Tom did
the profile on him he's covering the
Yankees and the Indians the senior
baseball writer from Sports Illustrated
also contributor to the MLB Network
joins us on the program
Tom good morning thanks for joining us
I'm curious if you had any trepidation
profiling a 16 year old putting him on
the cover and those words LeBron James
coming into the story you know we're
used to players being a little bit older
and they could handle that kind of
publicity but at age 16 any trepidation
absolutely Dan first of all when I went
to do the assignment I did not know it
was going to be a cover so just to do a
feature story in a magazine like si kid
who's 16 years old and really the world
hadn't heard of him it's not like an
Olympic gymnast who we see out there at
13 14 so to introduce the guy to the
national landscape at 16 I had a lot of
trepidation
first of all on two levels Dan first of
all there was no guarantee that this guy
would actually be that good right a lot
of youth sport is all about the
pituitary gland how quickly you develop
physically and mature at a young age you
get in bed when you do that early and
the other thing was just emotionally
intellectually you know how advanced I'm
at or was he in that regard to handle
that and I have to tell you Dan that
after watching employee but mostly after
going to dinner with him to his parents
I lost all of that trepidation I mean he
is an old soul kind of person anyway but
the maturity was off the charts at 16
years old this was a kid who knew
exactly what he wanted and how to go
about it and then to understand Dan that
he basically taken every at-bat in his
life his young life at that under
scrutiny and a lot of derision to be
honest with you because in the amateur
sports world and baseball everybody had
heard of Bryce Harper so there was
always a spotlight on him that was
something that he was used to has he
lived up to the billing
oh I think he has when you look at what
he's done best on him and that is hit
home run and get on base with walks what
he's done through this age 26
it is a Hall of Fame type
very few players first of all get to the
big lead to get nineteen he had one of
the best teenage seasons at 19 so yes
this is what he is it's easy in today's
world to say what he is not is not a
high average hitter he's certainly not a
contact hitter he hasn't been a great
outfielder but remember he was a catcher
growing up right everybody decided he
was just so good offensively he couldn't
put him behind the plate you wanted to
keep him fresh so to me my comp fan is
ready Jackson right would you say Reggie
Jackson was one of the five or ten best
players of all time
no would you say that Reggie Jackson was
one of the five or ten players who would
pay a ticket to watch play the answer to
that is yes he makes teams play makes
things better and he makes the King a
heck of a lot more interesting because
of the way he plays if I said you could
have Christian Yelich Cody Bellinger or
Bryce Harper oh man you put me on the
spot I would go yelets listen again with
Bryce I think what he also does is he
takes a lot of attention away from
teammates which is actually a good thing
right
the pressure was always on him
spotlights on him but Yelich and
Bellinger have just been off the charts
now for an extended period of time
Christian a little bit longer than Cody
you know Cody struggled a little bit
last year towards the end of the season
not a lot of separation between the two
but they do the two things I think right
now are the most most valuable things to
me offensively they hit with power and
they make contact you know there's no
sacrifice with batting average or
strikeouts with those two guys it was
with Cody before but he's made some nice
adjustments the two pitchers who signed
this week
Kimbrel with the Cubs in el Dallas
Keuchel with the Braves more of an
impact this year which pitcher Kimbrel
for me assuming the Cubs are a playoff
game because he can impact a series in
October I know it wasn't a great series
or impact last year in the postseason he
was tipping his pitches but in terms of
Meade absolutely the Cubs I thought
weren't going anywhere without some more
depth in their bullpen they've got that
a guy who keeps the ball to play Michael
to me is gonna be fascinating Dan I do
think it's a great sign by the Braves
because there's a younger staff that
walks a lot of people and he's going to
take the ball deep in the game
but as you know he pitches the contact
right I mean you need a great left side
of the infield which I think they have
in Atlanta the ball is going to be in
play my concern would be how long does
it take him to ramp up to be on point
because he has to be precise with his
pitches and we've seen guys miss timing
side late who struggled when they first
got back on the mound so I think the
impact was a little greater for Kimbrel
I think he'll hit the ground running in
about three weeks with the Cubs he's Tom
Verducci the Sports Illustrated senior
baseball writer and also contributes to
the MLB Network I'm not sure how to
phrase this and I hope you know where
it's coming from but there was a point
where baseball was the sport and then
all of a sudden started to slide a
little bit I don't know if it was
sliding as much as other sports we're
then gaining momentum whether the NBA
and certainly with the NFL but where
baseball is now how did baseball get to
be where it is now and is there anything
that could change the popularity of
baseball on a national scale in your
opinion yeah I think baseball got to
where it is now dan based on all the
complication that you referenced not
just other sports where you think even
he games and video games
remembered baseball did NLB did a
research project a few years ago what
young kids what are they doing more of
and less of and in terms of sport across
the board all the sports were down the
one thing that was up was doing nothing
no sports that's not a good sign for our
country but I think because there are so
many options now people have gone in
more different directions it's more
splintered so baseball now has become
super strong regionally right when you
look at all the TV numbers it just kills
it in terms of TV ratings locally
throughout the course of the summer and
all-star game World Series I know it's
not what it was but it's still winning
those times lot and it's very comparable
to the top shows and today you can't
compare it to you know mash and Seinfeld
and Cosby and back in the day everything
splintered so to me the fact is that
baseball is super strong regionally but
not as much nationally and getting back
to Bryce Ben that's to me the anomaly
about Bryce why he's so valuable he's a
national baseball star with a brand
who's never been in the World Series the
list of guys you could say that about
today's game it's about it he's about it
because you know
whether it was David Ortiz or Derek
Jeter at Buster Posey or mookie betts
you pretty much need to get to that
national stage for the country to really
know you and fall in love with you but
people know who Brice is and he's never
gotten out of the first round that's a
credit to him and how he plays the game
but yeah baseball just needs to pick up
the pace you know that dad right the
game is great I love the game I think
it's consumed by more people than ever
before I just like to see that as well
as it's played and played at a super
high level it goes along a little bit
quicker what is the big holdup or what
would be the holdup of using the screens
all the way down the foul poles with
baseball you know after what happened at
the Astros Cubs game yeah that's a good
question I mean some of it may be season
ticket holders who quote-unquote don't
want an obstructed view but listen some
of the most expensive seats are right
behind home plate right for years and
years and people didn't mind it and I
think technology as well as health in
terms of the netting now is not nearly
to me so obtrusive I mean it's a lot
thinner and stronger you know if you go
watching baseball game in Japan it is
pretty much all the way down to the foul
poles and the game's super popular there
so it may be just a matter of I don't
know just physically getting all the
material out there but intellectually
emotionally I think the sport should be
completely dedicated to getting it done
as soon as possible yeah I was surprised
the Commissioner took a week to say
something publicly and I believe he was
in Seattle when he said it saying hey
you know what we don't don't have the
resources I believe I'm paraphrasing to
be able to do this I understand that but
I wanted the Commissioner to just I mean
why not just come out and say you know
we can't do it this year don't have
enough time to be able to do it but we
will have it in play you know next year
on opening day or something like that if
you truly want to make it happen then
you will and if I lose season
ticket-holders because they don't get
the true fan experience
nobody ever turned down seats behind
home plate no one but if I lose a
four-year-old in the process of
something like this you know what I got
an heir to the side of caution here if
I'm the commissioner and he put these
these screens that went to the dugout he
already had the power
be able to do that I believe so why not
hey I'm the commissioner and I want to
protect my fans you'll still be able to
get foul balls and trust me when I would
send a piece of the netting to all of my
season ticket holders so they could look
at it and just understand this is not
going to interrupt your your experience
going to the ballpark well here's
another thing and I agree with you a
hundred percent Dan I think there's a
way and I'm not an expert in netting but
I think there's a way that you can have
retractable netting so that pretty game
those Nets can be up because a big part
of the baseball experience is you know
going down to the field to see the
players up close you can get an
autograph or two there's nothing like
baseball is unlike other sports just the
tangible nature of touching the game
physically touching the game whether
that's a foul ball or an autograph it's
a huge part of the fan experience
that'll make you a fan for life so there
must be a way so that screens prior to
the game can be up so you don't lose
that feature of the game and then once
the game starts for protection they go
down I think that's great that's a great
point because you go to batting practice
and you have the screen there the cage
there in batting practice so you're not
worried about getting you know liners
down the right or left field line and
that allows you to get right on you know
that the edge there of the field and
maybe you get a foul ball maybe somebody
throws you one maybe you get an
autograph I think that's wonderful
when that game starts I'm sorry you know
we're gonna put up the netting and you
won't even know and after a while you
just won't yeah and the fact is today's
game there are more foul balls than ever
before you know I usually spend a lot
because it's so crazy to think about
last year and this year for the first
time there are actually more foul balls
than there are balls and play think
about that when you go to a game and
I've realized not every foul ball
actually goes into the stands but you
actually have a better chance of feeling
the ball and the players in the field
wait but why more fennel bones
well because pitching is that good it's
not just velocity either there's a
breaking ball percentage especially
sliders have gone up it's hard to make
contact so too square for baseball now
is really something special so you're
saying guys just missing the ball and
that means more foul balls and also
dovetails
relief pictures that come in you're
facing all these fresh arms but yeah
there's more foul balls and balls in
play in today's game so this is not a
trivial matter we talked about speeding
up the game but who came up with that
you get what eight pitches when you come
in from the bullpen you just you were
just warming up now I give you a two and
let's go like why don't why am i giving
you eight and then the next guy who
comes in two batters later gets eight
you're speaking my language here imagine
the NFL with a backup quarterback comes
a time out throws it on the field
no I used to be because the bullpen
mounds back in the day when stadiums
weren't kept up that well they were very
different than the game mound so they
allow the pitcher to get used to the
game map now it's all the same I I would
give a pitcher two or three that's it
there's no reason for you thank you Tom
great to talk to you
all right that's Tom Verducci in
Cleveland today and tomorrow covering
the Yankees and Indians the yes senior
baseball Raider at Sports Illustrated
for more Dan Patrick show tune in the
audience channel 239 on DirecTV stream
for free on BR live or download the Dan
Patrick show app
[Music]